how's go Russ beautiful I got more
packages from the tour and I thought it
would open them don't eat that
Edgar loves it already I got so much
stuff from your bros and right away a
blanket really really appreciate it
thumbs up wait oh there's a note in the
blanket
dear pips I made this blanket in honor
of your birthday
and your game I didn't finish it but
still wanted you to have it oh it's a
pixel or okay how does this work
ed guy seriously I think I see it that's
awesome
you bro see it looks very disfigured
thank you that's amazing
honestly thank you so much an amazing
painting I remember the girl who gave us
this she was still painting it while she
was in the line so I grabbed it and I
think my thumb is on here somewhere
cuz it was still wet and yes incredible
thank you very much
I don't know why but thank you thank you
very much an awesome cup with a hole in
it love drinking glasses with holes in
it I really appreciate that thank you
very much abut slash face towel if
you're a real man your wife where your
blood has been that's all I'm gonna say
about that a very pretty dress I just
realized this is probably for my tía oh
well
oh my god [ __ ] me Oh and feebly when I
started my youtube channel five years
ago I knew that this was the end goal
and I really feel really proud right now
no matching hat a duct umbrella I
actually really like this way wait I
click the duct to expand Oh amazing
amazing super cool sunglasses when I
hear him come on my fuse and then Baba
it is me later
a fart whistle [ __ ] hell is diarrhea
whistle oh hey dollar oh yeah
the bro man himself the resemblance is
you can't miss it
you should see my [ __ ] face mug this is
so cute so this is a jar filled with
like nice comments that they're telling
me to read if I ever feel sad that's so
nice
all right here we got dear PewDiePie you
really suck
yeah will you swallow Oh the most kawaii
painting you have ever seen in your
entire life Zelda the Wind Waker on
GameCube thank you
what's that why do you never put me in
the channel any more parts actually it's
perfect that you guys are here because
someone sent awesome outfits for you oh
my god yes how the [ __ ] is he supposed
to wear this
this is gonna be mission impossible to
put on it game again you're gonna wear
this for 10 seconds I dare look cute and
that's all you gotta do alright yes look
at him he looks so good
good job I think they got the sizes a
little bit wrong oh I don't like this
also God from Save the Children they
came by for the tour it was really sweet
and it says Thank You pewdiepie and the
bro army they're an amazing charity I'm
so happy that we can support them
alright that's it for all the stuff
thank you Bruce for all giving me such
crazy and weird items thank you for
watching this video if you enjoyed leave
it a like and you'll win nothing
absolutely nothing you're trashed no
wait I got that wrong you're amazing
thank you so much brofist do you want me
to get fat this is crispy speed seaweed
hot and spicy let's try them out yes oh
I like it eight out of eight